folks joe derosa here from the taste
buds podcast hi taste buddies i got
dates coming up all over the place i
will be in atlantic city in august in
september i'll be in san diego
uh then i'm going to be in north
carolina i'm going to be in vegas i'm
going to be all over so just go to joe
derosa jodarossainfo.com for all ticket
links and tour and show information also
please as always check out joey rose's
in new york city on the lower east side
bar and sandwich shop and social club
we're running six days a week opening at
12 p.m every day go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for details
fear not if you didn't hear your city
these just went on sale for the fall
they're all on sale right now hamilton
ontario toronto richmond virginia
hershey pennsylvania knoxville tennessee
atlanta georgia birmingham alabama
louisville kentucky evansville indiana
jacksonville tampa and orlando florida
sacramento san jose and santa rosa
california if you didn't hear your city
i'm going to be adding more for the new
year but i'm grinding out there guys i'm
listening to you guys online when you
tell me come here come there i'm taking
into consideration so if you know
someone from those areas let them know
i'm coming through everything's on sale
right now volcano comedy.com thanks guys
tastebuds they coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools gonna fight
but only one food can be right
welcome to
t-a-s-d-e
we got the are you garbage kids back in
the house
we're switching it up today now i'm team
foley and i'm team kev baby
and we're battling snapple versus
arizona we're team arizona you guys are
teams you better believe in me
on the right side of this argument yeah
well
um i love snapple but i'm gonna go
arizona because i love foley
and i feel like we might have a fun time
battling you sure don't get me wrong if
i was on your side there are i can there
are things i can argue forever there's
pros and cons of each other
i mean come on yeah sure it's not going
to be a full-on like that you have stuff
to bring to the table 100 but we have
made from the best stuff on earth
so we'll see what happens what are you
guys made from what's something
about yeah the war of 1812.
ric celebrates asian culture i'd like to
point out uh
it's from like connecticut it's not even
from arizona it is weird you guys throw
that celebrate other nations yeah and
other cultures but does isn't the
arizona um like like their their
aesthetic like aztec type of designs my
favorite is the green tea with honey and
that is oh that's a classic
that's all classic like geisha girl i'll
tell you why i'll tell you a lot but why
wait yeah but they're just merging all
these called arizona iced tea geisha
girls on the can like the
they're saying this is where the green
tea comes woodbury new york woodbury new
york that's where it's iced tea juice
cocktails and energy drinks first
product was made available in 1992 to
compete with snap
which they did
you comfort a king you best not miss
that's right we're throwing down the
gauntlet right there arizona rep in
honor of the arnold palmer officially
yeah come on tell you something right
now come on i thought they reduced
themselves current day to those 99 cent
tall ball cans that's what they've
always been that was that was nice they
used to have this wonderful
oh no yeah
and i used to love that that diet gin
thing yeah which they put in the other
one but it was a blue bottle a dark blue
bottle i used to get all the time
they're still selling handles yeah and
they're still selling those those yeah
well they sell the big the big this is
so in the vinyl wrapped bottles too
though aren't they yeah yeah so the
glass bottles are still good i don't
know if they're made of glass still but
it's the vinyl wrap bottle i mean it's a
beautiful i think you're saving grace is
going to be with the glass bottle
that's what i sampled it away with the
glass bottle and that's kind of when i
started that's why
we've all made sure they [ __ ] up what
are you guys perfect yeah i don't think
so i will tell you though if i'm gonna
be honest and i'm gonna be uh i was
upset about snapple and and then going
to the to the to the place you're not
gonna try to put something on there that
says like even less weight they tried to
like get the environmental plastic
bottles if you can't do this the hit on
the bottom yeah
to loosen it up a little bit and get
that snap yeah get it out you're proving
our point on a glass bottle is just
forget it it's it's you know but anyway
we'll come back to it when we get into
the actual battle what that's what that
was that's what the snap snapple the
snap along the on the bat on the on the
cap why is it called snapple i don't
know oh i thought you meant because you
snapped it i for a company they didn't
bring apple into their flavors until
decades in it's weird that they're good
yeah yeah well that hit the when that
was a tour de force when it hit that
came years move mountains and change
people's lives i'm just saying though
they started out with straight up iced
tea straight up and short the last
amenti a raspberry tea and lemon tea
uh why it was called snapple i don't
understand
the original name
the original name of that particular
apple product snapple was
i don't know what that means uh
snappy or app what that does that might
that might make sense anymore the word
snappy and apple because the new name
became the new name for the beverage
company i read that because of the
camera and the glare see they're idiots
they don't know what the hell they're
doing
i actually it has to be why they named
it that somewhere in there the original
name of the particular apple juice
product oh here it is
yeah a port portmanteau portmanteau
isn't that how that's i don't know it's
a combination of
this
isn't it it's a combination of words
isn't it
an early apple juice product led to the
company's name snapple golden greenberg
and marsh had created a carbonated apple
juice one
one of the batches of apple juice
fermented in a bottle causing the bottle
caps to fly off
i guess that's where they got the snap
maybe okay
so it's a dangerous product
it's hurting children's lawsuit you know
what doesn't hurt children and ice cold
pounders killing people by the dozens
what are you talking about
anything better than than cracking a
little tall boy
that's where alcohol is that's for dry
drunks to feel yeah
oh it's great that that that's so
satisfying
when i used the bartender we had i did
this thing where i got you know you know
you guys know what nips are sure of
course so we i used to get the uh the uh
colt 45 nips and i used to serve them
they were the little ones right and i
used to serve them in little little
brown paper oh that's really telling
that's a good time it's a good time so
let's talk about this yeah so let's talk
about a company a family we're not into
we're not in the battle yet oh okay
we're not i know i thought we were small
we could shoot debris sure all right i
want you to remember
i came for a nice fight
i want you to remember what you wanted
to say there okay yeah well don't forget
yeah
now that you stopped it in the tracks
what do you want to talk about i did
want to run this by you guys
i'm just trying to follow some sort of
rules that we made on this podcast
that's all yeah i'd like you to back me
up
she should have two-way have two collabs
on the way i mean let me tell you i
don't like this no cheez-it though is
having a renaissance period oh i would
call it an identity crisis i would call
them an identity crisis and then and and
they're they're getting too far away
from the original cheez-it that's all
you need to do just like with arizona
iced tea we don't need staple apple and
peach
keep it simple with the basics you gotta
know you know he's got nothing to his
argument when he starts making noises
i gotta be honest i regular cheez-it is
okay it's always better i switch sides
the regular cheese in my whole life was
like all right it's a cheese it is you
bite it but now they have like uh they
have the bacon
toasted that's extra toasted right the
one with the with
uh
they got sour cream now they also have
different they have larger ones and they
have ones with the waves and they have a
cheese it is a mediocre snack at best
you're nuts you're crazy
[Laughter]
that spoke up and said we need to do
more than a cheese no the the original
cheese it is is a waste of a snack it's
a waste of my time nuts
the point is the last thing i want is a
giant cheese it with taco bell stuff on
top of it doritos made sense to me i'll
try to use it that looks pretty doritos
i like that you could have 27. how big
is that
is it wrapped in a cheese oh you're
really yeah that's nice i believe so
it's not wrapped in a cheese it's got a
giant cheese and on the inside is that
that's a that's a giant so how big is
that cheese it likes four by fours
years ago they should have stuck to the
original menu that was it they start
doing all this hollywood
i got a question how do you guys feel
about the cantino where you can go get a
beer the taco bell canteen
i've only heard of them there's a bunch
of them in new york i've only heard it
you can pop it it's like a bar you pop
in you get your fast food and then you
can get beers i gotta appreciate it also
you can get beers at chipotle and nobody
takes advantage of it there's one right
by gotham on eighth and whatever i love
the idea
i hate that there's no hard liquor
jesus christ this guy goes all in what
do you do you don't like a nice beer and
a mandela from taco bell have some
tequila
i mean i wouldn't make a racial
generality like that you're talking
about drunks in college
my point is is you go the taco bell you
got a cantina i want a shot in a bedello
and then i'm moving over to get
something i swear to god i could go for
one of those right now that you say it a
beautiful nice chill tequila to sip on
with a nice ice cold beer i can make it
happen for all of us if we so choose i
want to say something you got ice cold
brewskies i do what do you got i got uh
i got rolling rock come on and i got uh
what is it
we just got a couple the other day
because we had company
i see a yingling in there i'm not gonna
lie i can't spot a jinger
[Laughter]
um i just want to say that you said that
putting a cheez-it in the middle of that
burrito was a hollywood [ __ ] yeah
that's ridiculous
it stuck with me you shouldn't have hard
liquor because you can't mix a cheesy
gordita crunch with a dirty martini what
do we don't speak you you gotta be drunk
then you go to taco bell you don't get
drunk out of tacos that's what i'm
saying you guys but then i get a few
shots and have beers and then i move
over to the taco bell you can't do that
that's a bank job you don't hang around
in a taco bell spices you don't want to
dump the keel on that icee no you don't
do that fine come on twisted freeze you
guys taco bell you're in and out no they
do they got rum tequila vodka
man it's a
problem going dude
i i would be scared to go in there yeah
you don't hang out it's it's
putting you're doing happy hour at a
taco bell
i'm gonna get all tagged like a taco
you first gotta get thrown out of a taco
bell
holy [ __ ] man i'm going dude i noticed
you guys we were talking about movie
candy before the start of a movie movie
options yes and you said you go cherry
coke always
when i really want to throw down and i
normally right now i go to the let's be
honest i go to the movies now i maybe
get one thing of candy i can just choose
to get a water if i'm being honest
if you're throwing down if i'm throwing
down yeah i gotta go cherry icy
cherry ice cream i respect that it's not
i love it don't get me wrong i have been
tempted that's the first thing you've
i've been tempted by the temperatures
for the cherry icing many times and i've
got i've given in it's not a good
sustainable drink through the viewers
it's not a movie drink for me i love it
i like when it melts a little bit
disagree i think that there's stages of
it and they go they go they coincide
with the acts in the movie it's great
but i like when i see her a slurpee on a
hot day as i walk through the city
i've never had a slurpee walking out on
this slurpee in a car you drive
get
get drunk
7-elevens all over manhattan now you
stopping one you get yourself a nice mix
of the cola and the cherry
i like it slurpee
walk through the city with that slurpee
on a beautiful day i mean dude yeah
maybe
yeah you'll be as happy as you're living
in a movie you feel like you're a
commercial yeah it's
you guys like in the summer something
not not a hot hot summer night but i
sometimes i like walking to the spots oh
that's my favorite thing of new york
comedy is running spot to spot i love it
a nice summer night
running through like washington square
park or whatever i feel the energy of
this i just feel like i'm really
contributing to this yes i feel like
also
i got
it's a delusional thing i feel like i'm
the most important person in the world
i'm like get out of my way i gotta tell
jokes to nine people you know
from one place that i was important to
another place one i'm making the city
last tonight i feel like i'm a surgeon
i'm like a doctor like i'm like yeah
like i'm an ambulance like everybody's
scootch like there's an important guy
here i have to go lunch your pager is
going off music in the headphones and i
just feel like i'm in my own look
yeah you're in a movie yeah yeah the
league character you're moving when i
walk through the city i've been going
headphone less whoa i was always a huge
music guy as i walked but now the sounds
of the city really yeah i enjoy she got
to keep your head on a swivel over there
i enjoy taking in the sounds of the city
you hear conversations and you hear you
know what i mean i've enjoyed it lately
yeah i only do the music when i'm going
for spotify normal day in the city i
don't
so i understand what you mean really
yeah
i'm just trying to spot to spot yeah i'm
sorry okay yes
i can't speak to that i can't remember
the last time i walked spot to spot
oh you got on a beautiful night one of
my favorite things sometimes i'm just
saying i usually
usually just stay at one club now or
tonight i get that cause i'm old and
lazy but anyway um
what were we talking about we talked
about movies and slurpees and things
like that yeah what a good time
by the way
oh oh accused oh i wanted to tell you
the story okay
because q is talking comfortable first
yeah i don't like joe on this couch
he was talking about the beer pong
rivalry on this podcast okay and we
played we played on the fourth of july
q's house and there was a lot of play
this year because you didn't play in the
pool my title still holds i still hold
the title really
uh
played with no voice played with no
voice that is true true champion brought
it but q and i it's a blue game
real warrior over here you and i see the
flip-flops you will that day you don't
need to talk
flip-flops
no he comes in his converse okay the uh
no i nice change in the flip-flops
what's up get it there because i don't
want to walk you through it
changing these flip-flops yeah why not
that's crazy that's a little change
flip-flops i don't want to walk in the
city street to my car in my flip-flops
right because it's going to get city
[ __ ] all over the flip-flops yeah the
cars are not going to work
flops in manhattan i i wouldn't i would
know but i'm going from the apartment to
the studio
do all three of you have add or is it
just
god i have never seen
yeah you see one thing the conversation
guys
we're on we're on beer pong and we're
off sideways on the flip-flops three
blocks
you're carrying flip-flops around i'm
sorry i got questions yeah i mean it one
will let into the other you just don't
want to come along for the ride what
happened no i'm a real there you go
this is the guy i gotta worry about
what's the party he's talking about by
the way
that's what that's what you look like
after you win three rounds of beer punk
he he was there for over an hour
sleeping as the party
as the party went on
i never got out of the pool that looks
like a very nice deck i got a nice hot
dog too i'll tell you i was chillin
who clinches a hot dog in their sleep
like that that's crazy dude that's like
a dad with the remoteness
can i say this on that on that on that
close-up of the hot dog
that is out of the [ __ ] commercial
yeah zigzag that's a gentleman right
there it's also out of the commercial
for aaa if you
[Laughter]
what's up guys happy to be here where's
the beer pong table i put my flip-flops
on and i'm gonna take a nap
it was not a good way i had no voice you
fell asleep before the first bite
that's crazy could you wake up and eat
it though that's what i wanted of course
yeah no but did you eat it in one
sitting did you eat some and fall asleep
with a half of it no i woke up and do
that oh yeah wake up and my food's not
finished but i'm in the middle of eating
oh yeah oh far removed from the beer
pong talk are we at this point
just take the ride bro
i hate the ride i hate the ride i don't
like spontaneously
this
is joe's vietnam story yeah there i was
i had no voice my biggest pet peeve in
the world we were down to the last
podcast when it doesn't wrap up okay i
get so mad when i'm on anybody's podcast
they go okay so that's it and then they
go oh you know what else too
it make i see
red gosh i feel like you're getting it's
it's about now you're in the bonus
i don't like about it i'd like to give
you guys the best
we had the best ever back and forth one
two that we've ever had in the [ __ ]
talks okay
because as q said we should talk a lot
of [ __ ] okay so q said said there was
[ __ ] talking on the on that group chat
yeah days leading up to basically yeah
so q sunk a ball and said when you need
advice on how to play you come to me and
i said i'll come to you when i need
advice on how to run into a pile of [ __ ]
in the supermarket or i made some joke
about the practical jokers right
and he goes no
you don't get advice from me on how to
do that you get advice from me on how to
make money doing that
now basketball shout out to my mansion
wow
which was a stab in the gut right yeah
you're dead and then i threw one right
after that and i missed and he goes he
goes you've fallen from grace you're not
what you used to be you're like the band
when they don't have the original
drummer anymore and they got the new guy
and i go oh kind of like the impractical
jokers where they have to bring in
method man
he was like
fair [ __ ] point all right all right
that's great but it was it was our
greatest back-and-forth [ __ ] talk we
ever had and we were very very excited
can i say this you guys probably aren't
gonna believe me i've never played one
single game of beer pong wow now he's
not a fun guy
really what happened aren't the balls
dirty
no there's a water copy of rings
and what's in there beer or liquor
beer
[Laughter]
did you guys sympathy laugh at the story
because i said i wanted to tell it
everything that comes out of me is
really no it was real yeah i love it
that i put too much attention on the
story big beer pun guys [ __ ] talking is
80 of beer pong i'm in all right what's
going on something no i'm just handing
you your phone okay
[Laughter]
uh yeah
it's a real knife
jesus
sounds a little nervous what's going on
what is it
anything can happen
um no yeah but be a part is a fun game
but you're right it is dirty that's why
they they that he suggested ryan
suggested this year you
just drink out of your bag of your own
cup
yeah you don't drink you that's not
funny that takes this stupid yeah
and then i start playing immediately i'm
like this is the most fun game it's my
favorite yeah
it's like you're closest to be a
professional athlete there's so much
riding on it there's people cheering
yeah you're [ __ ] talking
i'm a horseshoe guy i like horseshoes oh
yeah yeah my dad just removed his
horseshoes
yeah would have had you over
of course you someone get [ __ ] up
oh sorry it's not as hip as horseshoes
i don't think i've ever seen it with my
own eyes you've never seen one i took
them off the markets were big a couple
of kids
they were killing it was all done guards
were big
yeah it was great it was fun man yeah
where was the lawn dart yeah yeah it's
right there yeah yeah now they're
weighted which yeah that'll kill you but
the ones with the spikes where you had
to get it it was an arrow there was yeah
an old-school lawn dart so i could see
what the hell happened who thought that
would be good that is a children's game
to throw a spear
i like how he typed in old school like
old wouldn't have worked jesus look at
that thing that's why yeah it's like
it's it's like a arrow that is insane
that they would make a children's game
you were supposed to throw them 20 yards
in all fairness they weren't um
they weren't like pointed like like take
one in the eye you could take them yeah
tell that to a little timmy
yeah like this mic and it would be the
same thing yeah it was just when it was
up in the air it got enough it got
enough momentum to go into the ground
lawn darts dangerous sharks but i'm not
even confused oh [ __ ] kill that old man
i'm not confused it would go through
your skin is that a downer on you
i think it was yeah that would easily
they were hurting people
anybody ever we just passed for the
fourth of july anybody ever have any
dust-ups with the fireworks
ever see something like go down no we
were crazy we never we were always too
scared to do stuff like that okay i got
hit in the eye with a firecracker pretty
bad
kid lit it and then it was like a fake
it would defuse but it went out okay and
he was like oh
like he would lit it they wouldn't light
and then like the fuse re-lit
at the base of it and he was like oh
[ __ ] and threw it
like just to get it out of his hand and
it exploded like right here oh my god i
was it was like i don't know it was you
know
the late 90s i was afraid to go to my
parents right i just kept my eyes closed
for two days i just slept for two days
no i couldn't open it it burned it stung
and we never went to the doctors or
anything
how's your vision who are you uh
that's fine yeah somebody said you can
get a chunk out of the white part of
your eye
they're like that's probably what
happened it'll grow like an egg white
yeah kind of like it's just like a
scratch on it or whatever yeah scratch
your corny i do that on my contacts all
the time yeah
i can't wear
and other serious injuries
cpsc who's that urges consumers to
discard or destroy all lawn don't
immediately destroy should not be given
away since they may be
harm to others consumer the government
how many deaths were caused by
go down one yeah there's 20 22 lawn dart
deaths
37 7 year old michelle snow was killed
by a londoner thrown by one of her
brother's playmates in the backyard of
their home in riverside california when
the dark penetrated her skull and caused
massive brain trauma oh machi machi a
kid three deaths in the seventies how
are they not banned immediately one guy
tried to license 20 years ago we take
our shoes off to get in the airplane
product safety commissioners with that
those consumer products so you can't buy
that version anymore but i bet you can
find an old an old one on ebay if you
really want to get gold at the party i
got to say that not to sound callous
three deaths you're taking it off the
market i'd want a couple hundred deaths
before i didn't play 100 couple hundred
you want
four deaths
i'm just saying if you weigh that what
do you if you weigh the pros and cons
what are the pros from lawn darts three
kids have died from swallowing jacks i
bet you know what i mean or whatever
anyone ever die from swallowing jacks
yeah but inherently the bunnies maybe
were you do you play with jackson
i don't get it if i've ever played them
the right way but are you kidding me you
bounce the ball you pick up every single
jack you catch the ball first try yeah
oh you're nuts are you kidding me you're
nuts when you buy jacks like when you
buy jacks at the store like yeah like i
used to get them at like the five and
dime
yeah well five in dime and it would be
like four or five jacks and the ball
that's it you're in your house that's
that thing you switch it's so much
harder than you think it is
it's just
i'm telling you from personal experience
i would like to buy jacks and see you do
it
that's fine okay do they still sell
jacks do kids know about jax did jack's
have any relevance today no not no here
yeah i don't see how it can be that hard
52 pickup you haven't played that yeah
look at this you you think you can swipe
all those up in one thing first of all
they're playing on a carpet and what are
those [ __ ] colors don't play with
anybody younger than three see look
there you go from metal so you don't
hurt your hand metal is the thing i know
what do you want from me
nothing is good anymore
that's all ten jacks small rubber ball i
guess maybe 10 i don't know if you could
get 10. but does it come with ten oh so
it just said ten years all it is is i
bounce the ball i grab as many jacks as
i can you bounce the ball you grab as
many as you can and the person who grabs
more jacks out of the ten jacks
so you could play a game i would argue
whoever goes first would win because
you're like you're gonna at least get
half right it's like tic-tac-toe so you
throw the jacks down
yeah that can't be it let's watch these
kids play
oh yeah oh okay he's not bouncing it in
a way that you it throwing it up what i
mean like yeah but all right isn't he
just going to sweep the board right now
no because he's adobe
he's also sick that kid stinks yeah he's
a dopey he's probably a lunchables kid
what's she doing what's going on here oh
you throw him like that yeah this is a
game that clearly came out of the turn
of the century yeah yeah there's no way
you're swiping all those once yeah by
the way there's no by the way what is
the uh the insanity of that [ __ ] talk is
is well i can't get around i swiped five
up right in the right well there's
something i also would bounce it like
that you know swiping but honestly it's
not i don't see it sustaining my
interest no no
that's for kids alone
why is the jack
that shape like what is the significance
you could pick anything up
yeah and i probably said well it won't
roll it won't because it's harder to
pick it's harder to pick it up it's
harder to grab a lot of them too because
there's this yeah
my argument is easier i'd rather have a
yo-yo
i was a yo-yo man or that paddle you
know the paddle with the ball on it that
never
shaped like that so you can actually
grab them
any other shape it would be flat you
couldn't you know knuckle bones
also known as scatter jacks snobs
that sounds like some old racist yeah
yeah hold on a second i thought they
would check a couple of knuckle bones
knucklebone sketches scatter jacks just
moved into the neighborhood
jesus christ
my knucklebone tenants won't snobs
asparagus what does it say astrologus
james cagney named these things tail
dibs five stones that's ancient acts of
jack stones it's a game of dexterity
is it no no yeah see you could play with
other objects stones seashells seeds and
cubes
oh man well they did they were starved
this was like netflix then you could eat
the seashells afterwards
get a balanced meal
i used to go hunting for seashells i
love the beach loved it more than
anything in the whole wide world and
trade them like they were currency i
would paint them i would sell them i'd
do anything you get the big ones i'd
paint them put rainbow my name anything
you want to do the small you ever get
one that started getting ornate and like
aesthetically like really something to
look at yeah of course you feel like you
found gold yeah you were a kid
yeah
that's the thing many kids did
i didn't i had friends
you were playing
i can't believe that he was like you
painted him and i had friends because we
we've gone through extensive links on
this podcast that joe told us that he
was a loner as a kid he had no friends
and there was a no
i never bought his house and he played
in the ditch alone in the ditch with his
covers
oh my god yeah you played the manifesto
coming i never said hold on a second you
played alone i never you said you would
sit at the top of the ditch and ponder
life can i speak
i never said that i had no friends i
never said that
i said
i said i had times where i sat and just
stared into the ditch because nobody was
around and it was depressing
so does that not imply
when you told us you when i went to the
seashore i had friends when you told us
you were depressed and you were hanging
out in the ditch alone oh shut up i shot
staring and picking the picture that you
had just tons of bags i said staring
into it i feel like you just left the
party like guys i'll catch you later i
sat staring into the ditch right yeah
yeah yeah so you think that to me that
sounds like you were able to do that
then paint the seashell i mean that's
just me personally and stare aimlessly
into
[Laughter]
are you guys going to get salty on this
episode yeah let's get salty all right
because you're going this is the first
time i'm seeing this yeah you're already
there i i i uh well you better think
fast because time's up all right all
right ready
oh by the way so it's time to get salty
we say it's time to get salty three
times then immediately insult the uh
okay and then uh then you do it the
other way ready all right
it's time to get salty it's time to get
something it's time to get salty
i knew you i knew your jeep was gonna
die everyone knew it the second you
bought it
it was a stupid maneuver it was just a
matter of time he fulfilled its own
prophecy it was a dead jeep the day you
bought it and you just kept it alive you
sustained it for a couple of a couple of
months but uh that was a terrible
purchase everybody knew it and now
you're paying the price okay ready
because this is how i look every day
folks
have you ever been in a pinch for cash i
know i have and
you know sometimes you need a helping
hand that's just the way it is it's
nothing to to be embarrassed about it's
nothing to be ashamed of it happens to
all of us and it's happening to sadly
more of us during these tough times
that's where dave can come in and help
uh yeah
sometimes you're just getting hit with
unexpected expenses okay the fact that
you don't have the cash you need doesn't
mean that you're being irresponsible or
anything sometimes you get hit with gas
bills uh that are that are because of
gas inflation and it's just starting to
wear you out maybe you got a wedding
you're planning
maybe you're getting hit with a house
payment it doesn't matter
here's the thing it's a situation that
at some point in your life you need a
little more cash because you're tight on
cash and that's it so dave is the
banking app that can help you get up to
500 dollars instantly with extra cash
that's more money to fill the tank buy
the wedding gift plan the wedding catch
up on the bills whatever it is you can
finally tackle the expenses that have
been stressing you out without any
hangups there's no interest and no
credit check needed millions of people
have already downloaded the dave app to
get the financial relief they need with
extra cash so if you're in the pinch and
you need the help download the dave app
that's it just download it download the
dave app from the app store right now
that's d-a-v-e like the name sign up for
the extra cash account and get up to 500
instantly for terms and conditions go to
dave.com legal instant transfer fees
apply banking provided by evolve member
fdic
the future will thank you
folks i wear glasses why because i need
glasses so i love glasses they become
part of my life they've become part of
my everyday look they've been become
part of my everyday personalized style
one of the tough things though when
you're buying glasses is you got to
commit to frames and then you're kind of
stuck with those frames that's why i
like pair
eyewear they're allowing you to make
some really cool unique mashup frames
for your eyeglasses it's a very very
cool thing that they're doing you choose
a base frame okay and then you can do
this like magnetic thing where you put
on top frames and it's just really
really cool pair eyewear's base frame
and magnetic top frame combination makes
it easy for you to switch up your style
base frames are starting at just 60
bucks
and that includes
the prescription lenses that's a very
nice deal and there are hundreds of top
frame designs to match whatever base
frame you choose okay i tried this out
you go in and i you know i just i
quickly found some bass frames that i
really liked uh and then again you have
so many magnetic options to put on top
of that it's very very cool one of the
bases is called the square very cool
another is called the cat eye
if you're feeling a little more
feline-ish
six different colorways for every frame
including the classic black which is my
favorite because that's just how i roll
including
wilder colors too like remix blue
tortoise pear eyewear pear eyewear has
forged their own way
with designs and all their looks and and
they're doing everything in-house which
i like i think is very cool so you're
getting high quality eyewear at the
fraction of a price every pair purchased
pair provides glasses and vision care
for children around the world by the way
so that's really nice that they're doing
some good with the money they're making
so anyway get glasses as unique as you
are one pair infinite style starting at
just sixty dollars go to pair eyewear
dot com slash taste buds for 15 off your
first purchase that's 15 off at p a i r
i wear dot com
taste buds
okay here we go
time to p-a-t-t-l-e
all right we're going snapple versus
arizona foley i think we got our work
cut out for us here i got to say i think
snapple just by sheer popularity of
being the howard stern recommended iced
tea for sure he sold
and the seinfeld ice team sure uh for so
many years we're gonna have a hard time
but i will start by saying this in the
presentation department you guys got
nothing on us nothing you got nothing
arizona in the presentation department
you had a moment snapple had a moment
i'll give you that so what you know we
ran the 90s and 2000s right what are you
talking about
in the presentation department look at
our bottles and cans
snap one's got
baby we got all kinds of flavors and
looks first of all that was one of
foley's arguments was we only have three
t's there's ten thousand iced teas there
so you know that's out there
a little bit again in the presentation
department we've got what else comes in
that can
what do you mean malt liquor is the only
thing else that comes in those cakes
yeah you want to be a cool kid
arizona to me tastes like homemade iced
tea and i don't mean that in the good
way i think you do it's like bathtub gin
type stuff
it's huge arizona icy tastes like when
you used to take this powder and and
stir it up and make it real like sweet
and it was like oh my god snapple feels
like it was made by artisans no yeah
that's cool no it does
it's the greatest stuff on earth is put
in there pure sunshine
what's your favorite do you have a
favorite snapple flavor straight up the
middle lemon yeah or diet as if i'm
trying to watch my face
lemonade or diamond i think yeah okay
i'm i'm i'm the one i reach for all the
time is the diet peach i think it's the
best i think it's the best it's for
royalties is arizona even the plan i
don't think we even mess with diet i
doubt it
the regulations extra sugar i don't know
what i've ever seen
100
diet owners 100
horrible those things sauce now it is
terrible they don't even get cold you
can literally put it in the arctic it
doesn't get cold you know it gets cold
aluminum a nice cold aluminum
and it stays longer i mean look at this
and look at these
flavors oh gosh do you think you have
anything grosser than drinking bananas
doesn't have enough credit
drop a raka with cinnabus
because we have both everybody has that
yeah i'll have an artichoke snapchat
please some of those i'll put i'll put
my top five against your top five in a
heartbeat do you even have five no
that's crazy you're not fussing you're
not fussing with green tea with honey
ginseng tea whatever it is
[Laughter]
arizona
we have an honorable we've got the
official arnold palmer who said that
what do you mean on the wikipedia we
read it earlier he's got a contract
his face is on it yeah i fell in love
with the ap back in the day
yeah yours is called half an hour half
and half what the [ __ ] come on yeah but
we all know what it is guys sure i don't
care if you guys get that yeah you're
supposed to put in your car
a bunch of money arnold
palmer that's the name brand
representation that drink that specific
man
i think snapple has i think snapple has
three flavors not even yeah let's be
honest two flavors and and including a
diet is the third you've got peach and
you've got regular and that's it every
flavor outside of that you didn't even
name the iced tea gamut they're regular
ice cream
i'm not saying they don't have one
more than two flavors apple's regular
iced tea it's not great
arizona's
original recipe is so much better than
snapple
here
it's for children it's all sugar this is
this is for whatever you think we're an
adult do you remember do you remember
not as sugary as arizona that's why it
tastes good but this used to be in every
single snapple iced tea all the stuff
floating around in it yeah the fresh
brewery
that's because it was bottom of the
barrel ice tape
arizona you take off the top yeah
and i got news for you there was a time
sure let me let me hammer out this whole
point there was a time where apple where
snapple was the iphone it is and and we
were secondary now arizona's coming up
the pike where the androids were about
to take over now here's my point what
i'm saying with that not only have you
lost the glass bottle not only have you
lost the look you've also lost quality
because when they went to plastic
bottles and you couldn't do the bang on
the bottom all of a sudden snapple
didn't have any of that sediment in it
anymore it was gone yeah so the quality
in the ice tea dropped off to compensate
for the plastic bottles
one step further about that company
arizona okay
snapple's fluctuated in price you know
how much an arizona iced tea costs from
jump street 99 cents because they care
about the american public and they care
about the american consumer and they're
an american company
i will tell you i knew they were gonna
bring out about the recession there you
go the can itself they stamp it on the
can which is yeah it's insane 99 cent
great buy it so nobody gets cute trust
me nobody gets cute but they're they're
screwing the the little man
that's punk rock you know what you see
rock it's a major corporation who else
you should do that ian mccain used to do
that with the discord record bands
when i worked in a similar way
when i worked in a record store he would
put the price permanently on the thing
so the record store couldn't mark it up
so he's not ripping off exactly and
that's what arizona does the fact that
they're putting it on there just on the
cans yeah you can't you can't that's it
okay
what about you
what about the other seventy percent of
the product speak to that i'm speaking
to what the can cost the campaign
it's 24 ounces then you're getting a
double pound that's insane for 99 cents
that is for low lifestyle
i'm an established esteemed gentleman a
man of the man of the palmer business
owner
99 worth of sugar water that's what that
is that's crazy 40-24
show us what the best stuff on earth is
bring up the ingredients i'd rather
drink it i'd rather drink a brisk let's
see what the let's see what's the best
stuff i'd rather drink a brick
if i'm
give me a brisk baby give me a brisk
it's risk baby listen to me you have to
stop
you have the stones that's just
words click on the lemonade how can you
say all we have is
i'm saying you have two good flavors and
that's it it's such a joke that's what i
think
that's what i think you think
he doesn't believe it i don't like when
he does that look at me in the eyes
[ __ ] look me in the eyes you think
snapple swear to me you dick snapple has
two
good flavors maybe three you think maybe
three yes i think that now we all know
you'll do anything for clues
tell me another you sold your soul
you sold your souls
[Music]
tell me another staple flavor you're
reaching for raspberry get the [ __ ]
raspberry i was hitting dick two before
peach listen you guys are trying dude
arizona iced tea was invented to try to
compete with which they did yeah they
said we can make a better product that's
cheaper
you guys are picking up the clothes
you guys are the you guys are the stuff
float at the bottom
let's go ingredients to ingredients yeah
let's go ahead and let's go dietary to
dietary facts nutritional factors staple
has 36 grams of sugar pimp how many
grams of sugar does uh arizona which one
did you 120 yeah
it was a stem
standard lemon yes
so you're at 36 grams of sugar we have
24. look at that look at that hold on
but what
look at that
look at that
serving size yeah slide up this is
i can't see any of that guys sorry
that's eight fluid ounces okay so 20.
yeah but we're in a 20 we're in a 16
ounce bottle min
1 16 ounce bottle we have
36 grams double yours no it's quadruple
so what you're telling me they're 24
hours
oh right right right so what you're
telling me is i'm getting triple the
sugar for half the price
i'd be losing money i'm sorry if you do
if you do it uh apples to apples
snapples and samples it's six pounds
so i love you 36 they have 48. because
they they have
right there's 24 and an eight ounce so
if they're going six times three four no
but oh time sixteen sure yeah yeah so
you're still
so you you're still saying you brought
it up you brought it up right now and
you lost you lost but that sounds i
don't think so i think that's a better
value if you stick for more sugar says
you're getting you're getting four
drinks in one can
are you not nobody's nobody's splitting
that can up into it
that's here
diabetes in a city i used to always
stick to the strict serving size i would
have said a 400 pound guy on the couch
mania here we go folks
have you ever been starved for some
excitement in your life i know i have
what if you had a go-to game that could
instantly bring a healthy
hefty dose of fun to your day whenever
you needed it well gosh darn it i like
that sort of thing and you should too
that's where slot omania comes in it's
not just a fun word to say it's a fun
thing to play with life's too short for
a day without fun
get your thrills whenever you need it
need them with slotted mania the world's
number one free slots game you'll have
endless excitement at your fingertips
with 170 free to play slot games huge
jackpots interactive communities and
millions of free coins it's the perfect
escape from your daily routine i like
that this is free i like that you're not
really playing with any
money
like that it's just all free and all fun
and all great and and that's it it's
just a matter of of having a good time
uh you get a little me time in to relax
each day with it and i like the big mix
of the casino gaming the casual gaming
uh i i i really like the versatility of
this thing again you get one million
free coins when you download slaughter
mania to kick start the fun there's
nothing more exhilarating than winning a
huge jackpot even if it is of
free fake whatever you want to call it
and special prizes and free coins and
stuff like that slaughtering me slot
omania makes every day funtastic
what more could you ask for people
interact with fellow players and form
cooperative slotto clans with new
friends
or enter electrifying live tournaments
become a vip member and get your own
personal account manager connect with
millions of other slot fans on the
slaatomania facebook page one of the
biggest slots community in the world
go have some fun gosh darn it download
this thing when your day is starting to
feel stale just ask what will i spin
if you're 21 or older you can join
millions of players around the world
download slot oh mania the number one
free slots game on the app store or
google play store and get 1 million free
coins that's slottomania on the app
store or google play store for 1 million
free coins
folks let's talk about bird dogs what's
up bird dogs
i love birds i love dogs and i love bird
dogs smash them together that's a pair
of shorts anyone can love they're comfy
with a liner they're stretchy and you
can wear them anywhere i love these
things man they're popping with the
colors they're a lot of fun to look at
they're a lot of fun to wear they're
lined shorts what more can i say folks
these things are getting the job done
and i'm enjoying them quite a bit go to
birddogs.com and our promo code taste
buds and they'll throw in a free bird
dog's dad hat that's birddogs.com promo
code taste buds and boom free bird dogs
dad hat with the pair of bird dogs you
purchase
get your downstairs
you know what that means ready for
summer with bird dogs you will not take
these things off i promise you that bird
dogs and i would put it away for you
seriously once you open that can it's
still over there's no resealables no no
no reseal oh
wrangler certainly the only competition
certainly the only competition you have
versus us is the 99 cent can you're not
going to put bottle against bottle
that's wild no that's your models you're
wrong because the arizona bottles are
bigger they care about the environment
that's that's yours so the arizona
bottle has that nice wrapping paper on
the top of it that actually looks like
it's like a lone brown
i always have to take it off yeah first
of all
who's been on record is hating lone
brown by the way
i swear to god you bring it up it looks
like an old michelob remember when
mickeled had that gold tinfoil on that
side yeah
the guy was doing here
drinking one of those
she walked out on you a big guy a couple
of mickey loops
listen hey that's
it is
[Music]
hold on hold on you think your diet
doesn't have aspartame show us don't do
it no of course it does only recently
have people been doing that
and stuff like that
that's the good stuff and let me tell
you this who was the first one jody you
know this who's the first one
to go green tea to for a healthier
option
arizona ice takes do we have this
that's also conjecture get out you just
made it that's true usa
do not use aspartame or saccharin in any
arizona
look at that we do not do not we do not
do not so there you go you can have your
little uh less sugar enjoy the aspartame
i i will i'm going on i like what it
does
and you gotta say let's put let's put
your top 10 of your top five versus on
top ten on top five you're getting right
there let's go top one let's go let's go
original original original there's
nothing better than original snapple
you're crazy yours is pumped full of
sugar to make it taste good that's candy
to steak you got a primer you got you
got a filet and you're going oh here's
this here these are these m m's we're
not getting out
you guys you're pumped full of sugar let
me ask you they've got a little bit more
sugar
you guys are the go bots with a
transformer let me ask you guys let me
ask you this and be honest you tried to
compete with us that's your whole thing
let me ask you this
it's a summer day you're running around
with your buddies okay you go just like
traipsing around frolicking yeah
whatever you know you're playing
basketball you're doing whatever sure
does that bottle of snapple that small
tiny bottle of snapple actually hit the
spot or do you need to get two one does
it i always need to get it
we also come in at 16 or 20 ounce you're
forgetting yeah
if i want
jug for the fridge don't they yeah no
they they got taken off the market
because of the fentanyl all right i'm
telling you right now
but that's not the quest the question
isn't do you have a bigger size we're
saying people would drink two of yours
versus word of god sample no that's just
soft volume oh no you're just basing
that off what's offered
doesn't hit the spot
so one big arizona does yeah he's got
damn right yeah that's it
it's because it's more of more size you
dumb dumbbells
we're talking about 24 ounces versus 32.
no
24 of arizona satisfies against the 32
years 32 ounces of any beverage doesn't
it
too much 32 is crazy i'm saying you need
32 ounces of snapple to be satisfied you
need two of those
where are you getting this information
from that's what i do every time nobody
gets one snapping you got everything so
you buy snapple you say that yeah you
love it so much you buy two of them
when i have bought it i have to buy two
that's the 64. they can't finish the
whole hoagie with one 32 bucks
i'm getting the classic 12-inch hoagie
okay i ain't walking out with one snap
now i'm walking out hold on stop
we're saying you need 32 ounces of
snapple to equal the satisfaction of 24
ounces of arizona that's right
arizona because after about 16 or 18
ounces i'm like okay i'm good to go
should be good enough it's not
it's a different beverage that is so
arbitrary buddy arbitrarily you're
arguing to me that it's
you have to sell the question there's 24
ounces in arizona because the product is
superior satisfied with less arizona
than i am with snapchat also also they
don't even
you can look at the stores the stores
that carry both of them where you can
get a snap over it's only like gas
stations and stuff can you get an
arizona iced tea you can't walk into a
reputable establishment and get an are
you bad [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
walking down your grocery store aisle my
friend the primary jug of iced tea
you'll see is that i shop at a whole
foods
they don't they don't have it yes they
do it
they exist but i've never seen one in
the world because you shop at a gas
station you just said they're not mass
distributed because there's no market
for it
what there's no markets
i'm i'm a gentleman i go to whole foods
yeah
[Applause]
let's talk about the snapple facts
because we're glossing over yeah one of
the greatest games to take over possibly
talking about lies you want to talk
about lies that's all they are they're
not all by the way they draw lies they
turned on howard stern they turned on
hours on howard stern they had a huge
falling out with stern afterwards
he can't be trusted
[Music]
marketing budget or celebrity
endorsements to sell their products
are you
bozo
arizona's trying to get into marketing
their brand and clothes and sneakers now
can you believe because because their
stuff stinks so bad they do show they do
shirts and hats talking about not
knowing your identity they're trying to
go on sneakers now arizona look right
here arizona merchandise oh that's
beautiful where stuff's awesome that's
awesome i'd rather pimp you would wear
that whole thing come on look at that
every single thing
if i stunk at making iced tea i would
start making sure look at that look at
that design
for the green tape we're not talking by
the way like i can get a snapple t-shirt
that's fine you got a promo
that's really look at that that's a
woman's bathing suit this is a clothing
line yeah the full clothing it's all
awesome sorry that we're in the street
where we do it great i mean yeah they're
cool they're in touch with the tickets
is that a skateboard this is hundreds of
pieces mushrooms everything
is awesome that's all that's cool
pocketbooks i'm not saying it doesn't
look cool but
if you're
yeah yeah take us to the snapple merch
page if there even is one exactly we're
too busy we're too busy with the what
making uh the making busy ruining your
product yeah look there's a couple of
things
yeah you guys are doing everything else
but the beverages
yeah i think we
have two drinkable teas
that's all you need
come on guys this is what you're doing
this is awesome it's called vertical
integration gentlemen no it's called bad
products that's what it is i swear to
god this is absurd look at look hold on
look at that cam look at how fun that
[ __ ] can they're going to stash
that's a great company you guys are
rallying behind snapples for divorcees
that complain about people touching
their yogurt in the snack room fridge
arizona's for dudes to get [ __ ] up and
partied
[ __ ] nerds
did you guys have any idea that you
would have 400 non-iced tea products i
got no problem with it you don't have
any problems i would have a problem with
that why would i have a problem with
that why would i have a problem that
we're going to care about craftsmanship
really correct me if i'm wrong on last
week's battle you said lunchables didn't
had an identity crisis yes or no that
was one of your big gripes
i don't remember that i'm sorry
that's all the sugar went to his head
from that iced tea i complete the fifth
all right we gotta go to the phones we
gotta go to the photos crazy guys we
didn't even get the snapple facts
sure
there's nothing worse than a non-comedy
entity trying to be funny and those
stupid why don't you look at me
i've seen this sex i don't know good
singers those stupid jokes that snapper
put on the captions made me sick
the
timelessness of the
fortune cookie yeah in a way they put it
into the iced tea no no no oh so they so
they culturally appropriated so that's
another thing that snapples yeah there
you go that's nice and also i i read a
snapple factor today and said 911 was an
inside job all right so they're getting
a little nuts they're just getting
a joke it was first it was preface with
knock knock
can i ask this before we go i would like
to be curious who did the facts first
was it nantucket or snapple and by the
way
you guys got
i need you to read him because i can't
see him all right let's go to the phones
he's got diabetes from all that goddamn
iced tea his eyes are going simple fact
number six five seven nobody has drank a
snapple since the
the first time thank you thank you adam
prize
but that's how baseline is funny
is the number one selling guy and that's
george bush senior but
but you need you need to come with
something oh snapple just doesn't hit
the same since they change the bottles
arizona stays consistent and affordable
it's just nice
there you go you're going to you don't
have to go that fast snapple was the
best in the glass bottle but now it
doesn't taste good you picked that one
for snapple all you want but the second
arizona created arnold palmer the
conversation was over boom snapple is
what you choose when you're
off a drug bender for three days and
finally wake up and realize that you'll
you've made all the wrong decisions so
what's one more wrong decision a snapple
that's not true look at that one arizona
is the crocodile snapple apple deserves
respect true truth bomb oh well yeah
arizona arizona is the crocodile of the
drink world perfect from the start and
never required evolution very
interesting what are you talking about
they sell bikinis yeah 99 the problem 99
enough said yeah it's trash i doc
snapple a few points for getting rid of
the glass bottles snapple got rid of
those glass bottles and now it's cheap
plastic to match its cheap taste
i know but nothing's about to taste
there has been one about the taste apple
i don't like iced tea it tastes like
earwax
kid's eating earwax he doesn't know
what's going on you kidding me arizona
tastes like a warm hug from your mother
look at that that was tweeted by h
neville's the weird uncle thanksgiving
dinner that comes around saying where's
my hug yeah there you go hey you want to
hear a weird fact get over here and sit
on my lap that might be our winner
uh
was that would say anyone who gives out
a verbal hmm after reading a snapple
fact should be thrown into a gorilla
enclosure
do you want your diabetes in a few
flavors or
i can't read that
i don't know who that's about you can
feel the diabetes coming on while
drinking no that's the other way around
i know i hate tea
my father left me when i was very young
i felt nothing would ever provide the
emotional
stability i love and crepe one day i
stumbled upon arizona iced tea their
commitment to the price of 99 cents is
filled the hopeless void that my father
was
what does this mean there are more
chickens
than humans on the planet and snapple is
at the knees of arizona i don't know
what that sounds like a [ __ ] snapple
fact all right let's give the win to who
do you think the father tweet or the or
the gorilla
i gotta be honest i think i'm reeling
right now
my mind is blown yeah i thought the
wrong side boys
i thought this was a gorilla enclosure's
the funniest that's great all right give
it to grow i thought this was a no
contest to be honest with you me too
sorry follow me
i'm a little upset at misguided idiot
follow misguided idiot uh you're talking
about the coca-cola
like snapple he's the
dynasty it was it still is garbage guys
you want to plug before we go there's a
whole new update guys uh guys yeah check
out our podcast ru garbage it's
available wherever you get uh podcasts
we do two episodes a week on youtube the
whole nine yards we're on tour check
that out uh we're coming to
philly rhode island boston seattle
portland nashville everyone got like 20
dates on the books for the end of the
year check it out and guys do us a favor
go over to the arizona website pick up
some merch okay because there's more
because there's sales company that's
been supporting you all right uh if you
guys want to help our pod just subscribe
to the no press channel on youtube uh
rate us on itunes or follow us on
spotify any of those or all those will
help if you love the pod it's free help
us out do that merch is available on our
website savilechannelcounty.com
joederosainfo.com whole bunch of stuff
new stuff coming but this stuff is going
to sell out soon and we're going to have
new stuff so if you didn't get it yet
get it now and then we're on tour too
we'll have an insert for that right
pimpy yeah so just check our websites
but we're we're all over the place as
well all right
we're going to uh 9 500 give me a give
me a drum like this i got to be honest i
i i got to be honest man i
this is going to be i thought there was
going to be a landslide and i think it's
i think we're end up over here are we
that's if we're under the impression
that the comments will directly sure
i am shocked so am i man how
arizona leaning is all right here we go
oh
my god
here's a fact snapple sucks
how long you been sitting on that one
fatty about an hour
ten thousand votes we got fifty wow
seven percent arizona yeah you got a
smart crowd out there
out for people listening to this
i am podcast to my core right now i
can't believe i thought snapple was a
top that hill like nobody's my whole
perception of the world
and they fell off i'll tell you what oh
i see it's very clear to me from the
comments and i thought it myself that i
i like the glass bottle better of course
they're eating [ __ ] over this glass this
glass of plastic bag really changed the
game for them because they're working
for the environment
they did not do that i don't think you
had a change quality of the t dropped
when they went to the bottom they had to
change the the mixture i'm telling you
there's no more of the sediment in it i
agree
there's no sediment there is like a dust
it's not a sediment it's like it's just
it's not the same it's not the same but
in the heat of the battle i have to i
have to try to
[Laughter]
let's get back to the glass bottle you
heard it here first i still think you're
the king but you gotta you gotta you
gotta know when you made a mistake
remember when coke made coke two
yeah a new code then they were just like
witches
yeah they didn't label everything they
went back to and then then it's got
stamped original coke because you can't
mess up you can't fix something that's
not bro yeah that's what snapple did
they got too big for their britches in
any case we still love you we love you
we love you guys let's have an arizonan
enjoyable man
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right